- When I went back,
Dave, during Covid-
- [David] Yeah, it was nuts.
- What the hell happened
to these people?
What happened to them?
What happened to the show?
What's going on here?
I mean, I got, I went
through a full pre-interview,
they knew exactly where
I stood on the mandates.
I was naive, I was
naive, I felt like,
well, they know where I
stand, I'm gonna go on,
they're gonna have a real
conversation with me.
I don't know why I thought that,
but I thought, well,
it would be ridiculous,
I was a former cohost, It
would just be so disrespectful
to do anything but have
a real conversation.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today is a
former co-host on "The View,"
former Fox News anchor,
and author of two
best selling books,
and now host of the
"Jedediah Bila LIVE Podcast"
on Valuetainment
TV, Jedediah Bila,
welcome to "The Rubin Report."
- Thank you for having me, Dave,
always a pleasure to be
here, always a pleasure,
in this Florida
heat, nonetheless.
- In this Florida heat.
So that is a good
place to start us off.
First time, first off, many
of my viewers will know you
already from the million
things that you've done.
And you've been on the
show on The Panel before.
We've never had you
for a proper sit down.
That's why I wanted to do this.
And I should note for those
playing along at home,
that this is airing in August.
I am off the grid, I
have no phone, no TV,
no news, no nothing,
but we did wanna pre-tape some
stuff for you good people.
And Jedediah, I thought you
would be a good one for this
because you are like me,
you are a new Floridian,
and I sense that you are
living your best life
since fleeing New York.
- I am, I'm loving the vitamin
D, I will tell you that,
the sunshine, and the freedom,
that's why I came here.
I have a two and a half year old
and it's been really amazing.
I lived in New
York, my whole life
so there's always that
hesitance to move, right?
And I was one of those
people that was like,
no, I'm gonna change New
York from the inside,
I'm gonna stay, it's almost
impossible to do that.
It really is hard when people
continue to vote like robots
in those places.
And it's just like, oh,
who's on the ticket?
There's a D, it could
be a total moron,
I'm just gonna vote for them
anyway and wreck the city.
So I picked up, I came out
to Florida and I have to say,
it's just the feeling,
it's just more calming.
I feel like now my views of
like, you own your own life,
you're a free individual,
you're a free citizen
now align with a
place that I live.
Plus, how exciting
is it gonna be
to actually vote in a place
where it's exciting to vote?
Because it's like, you
never know how it's gonna,
we're always watching
Florida, right?
We're always like New
York and California,
yeah, that's decided
in like 20 seconds
after the polls closed,
but Florida's always kind
of like what's gonna happen?
So I think it's really exciting.
It's an exciting
time to be here.
I think Ron DeSantis it's
doing a fantastic job
showing a lot of leadership
while a lot of other Republican
governors are asleep,
and it feels good, it feels
good to be here right now.
- Well, I don't
wanna disappoint you.
I know this isn't gonna
really disappoint you,
but don't worry,
we're a red state,
this place is staying red.
DeSantis is gonna
crush it in November.
It's gonna go red no matter
who's running for president.
So I know that's not as exciting
as being in a swing state,
but nonetheless.
I know for a fact, I got
here on December 17th, 2021.
What day did you get here?
Do you know the day?
'Cause for me, it's etched
in my brain in stone.
- I don't remember,
we've been here for about four
months now, but I don't...
- You were a little behind me,
you were about two
months behind me or so.
- I was, I was, and we changed
our date a number of times.
And then it was really
funny when we got down here,
the place that we had
planned to live in
was not as advertised.
So we lived outta
hotels for a while.
So that's probably why it's
a little mixed up in my head.
But what I do remember is a
conversation I had with my mom
when I got here,
and that was the one
challenge, I'm a family girl.
So leaving my
family in New York,
they're not quite
ready to move yet.
Although now my mom
just came down here
and she's like, I
gotta get down here.
The one thing I remember
feeling is just,
I took a deep breath, I
was sitting on the beach,
and I was like,
wow, I just feel like I shed
a whole bunch of baggage
that I had on my back
in New York City.
There were so many restrictions.
And at the time it was in
the heat of the mandates
and you know, you're not
my friend, you're my enemy,
you didn't get the vaccine.
And it was like, all of that
just turmoil, the crime,
and it just felt
so, I felt light.
I don't know how else to say it,
I felt like light and airy,
and like I was ready
to like reembrace life.
And I think I did your
show soon after that,
on The Panel, and you will
know, you just sound different.
And I was like, well-
- You did, you did, that
was like two weeks after.
- Yeah.
- Yeah,
you were like jumping
outta your skin basically.
And I was like, oh,
I know the feeling.
I actually still
have that feeling.
- Yeah, yeah, no, 100%.
And I think, you know,
for people like us,
you're coming from California,
I'm coming from New York.
I think for people who
really believe in freedom,
I don't think we realized, at
least lemme speak for myself,
there was a lot of
frustration that was in me.
And especially
when I had a child
and I realized, wow,
this system is so broken.
And then I saw the crime and
I was like, what can I do?
And there was just so
much frustration brewing
that finally, to be in a place
where freedom is prioritized,
where these values
that we hold so dear
are front and center.
Where you're gonna raise your
kid in a place, you know?
And I don't know, listen,
I don't know if I'm gonna
be in Florida forever,
but I will tell you this, Dave,
I'm never going back
to a blue state.
I'm done, if I go anywhere,
maybe I go to Texas, maybe
I dip a foot in Tennessee
or you know have Florida ends,
I'm not going back
to that though.
There's a darkness and
there's a dystopian,
you know those dystopian movies
that we used to watch and say,
well, that's not
real life, thank God.
Yeah, that's what it
feels like tangibly in
a lot of these woke
cities around the country
and states and I'm
not going back.
- For the record, I am
never leaving Florida,
they will take me out two
feet first if they take me,
but I will be buried in Florida,
I am never leaving Florida,
I will be swimming with
the gators, as they say.
- Dave, you're committed.
I don't know, what was that
thing you had on the wall
at one point, it was
like some Florida,
I don't know what, was it
lizards or the little...
- Oh, well, it was
all meant to be for me
because I've actually always
loved Florida my whole life.
And my folks have lived down
here for part of the year.
So I've always been coming down,
so what you're talking
about, I had two,
oh right, you might be talking
about one of two things.
I have two giant
alligator canvases.
- There you go.
- These like six foot canvases
that I've had for years.
But I think what you're
talking about is that
we have a whole wall of
alligator skin wallpaper.
And one day I woke
up in the morning
and there was a lizard on
the alligator skin wallpaper.
And I was like, this
is as good as it gets.
- Listen, it's commitment,
it's commitment from you.
I love it.
And coming from California,
the thing is like a lot of
people go to California,
I say now the only sane people
that would go to
California is just people
who love the weather.
If it's not the weather,
I really don't know
what you're doing there.
You're not gonna grow
a business there,
the tax structure is
just not incentivizing,
it's not welcoming
to entrepreneurship.
I don't know why you
would go to California
if it's not a weather decision.
But for someone
like you, who does,
I'm guessing you're
not a fan of the cold.
I'm just gonna put
that out there.
- I don't love the cold,
but correct me if I'm wrong,
the summer's been
pretty fine here.
I know they're saying
it's unseasonably,
it's not raining as much as
usual, but it's been fine
it's fine, I like sweating.
- There you go, detox.
- Exactly.
So I wanna ask you something
because since we come,
I'm originally a New Yorker
before my crazy eight years
in Cali.
So since we come from
such a similar place
and now I think our
political outlook
and our sort of life
outlook are very similar.
What do you think
about the people,
the kind of people that were
the northeast people, lets say,
the New York people that
should have some fight in them,
the Cali people, a lot of
them just seem fried to me
or like northern Cali, okay,
wine country, SoCal, San Diego,
you're just sort of
fried by the weather
and okay, you just accept it.
New Yorkers have
a fighting spirit.
And that's why it was
so hard for me to see,
and I still have a ton
of family in New York,
so many people just accept it,
and not only accept it,
but like thank you, sir,
may I have another?
And they're bringing, as
I'm off the grid right now,
I don't know if mask
mandates are back in Cali,
they're supposed
to be right now.
And they could be
back in New York
and people would welcome it.
- Yeah, New York has lost its
soul, I've said many times.
I grew up there and there
was a rebellious spirit
in New York, it was
really rebellious.
And it used to be
an enclave for like,
if you went downtown Manhattan
was like artists and writers
and people who challenged
the status quo.
And of course, yes, the
city always was liberal,
but they would challenge
like corporate America
and big pharma.
I mean, big pharma
would've been a huge target
by those people.
They would've not been like,
they would've not liked
to be told what to do.
They wouldn't have been
like, oh, I got 16 jabs,
and I'm gonna be online
for the 17th one.
And it's okay to tell people
if they don't get a vaccine,
they can't go into the deli.
I mean, that is not the
New York that I know.
And I think that was what
was the big challenge for me
is that I saw a hypnotized
population just like,
kind of like the walking dead.
I mean, I hate to say it,
but just like kind of
robotically walking around.
When I say a
dystopian nightmare,
I mean a dystopian nightmare.
And it's just lost its
spirit, it's lost its soul.
I think that people have
become allies of the state,
you know?
And now it's just
like a bunch of people
who believe
politicians over there.
They've lost that
fire, that energy
and the city doesn't read
the same that it used to,
it doesn't read like a
hub of cultural activity.
I'm sorry, but it doesn't.
It reads like a
crime infested area
where you're afraid
to, you know,
you don't wanna
build a family there
because you're not only
worried about the crime,
but you're worried
about the mandates,
you're worried about what
happens in cycle two.
We all know there's gonna be
a cycle two of this pandemic,
it's coming, it's coming
and it's gonna be the masks.
Maybe it'll come just in
time for the next election,
who knows?
- You think, you think.
- You'd think, but the
next time it rolls around,
now, you know that, you know,
you can look around the country
and know where those
populations live,
where they're just gonna
lie down and take it.
Oh, you wanna shut
down my business? Okay.
Oh, you wanna mandate
that I get a vaccine
a vaccine that doesn't
stop transmission
or I can't go into
a restaurant, okay.
Like where is their
line in New York?
Just in terms of making
decisions for themselves
and their families.
So I don't know what caused it,
but now there's like a
subservience to authority.
It's like, oh, you're in
a position of authority,
you must know better.
Oh I must be, it's like,
everyone thinks
they're an idiot now.
Oh, I must just, wait, I
know I have common sense,
but I guess I must be wrong.
And Bill de Blasio at
the time must be right.
It's disturbing and
it's a lack of autonomy
and it's a lack of
self sufficiency
and a lack of personal
responsibility.
All those things I hold, dear,
they're just not there anymore.
On top of that,
you got the crime.
So you're like, wow. I
used to love New York
because you could
go out on the town.
Now it's like, well,
if I go one block over,
I might get knifed.
So maybe I won't do that either.
So it's a sinking
city in many respects.
And you know, my
friend Buck Sextant,
didn't put a tweet out
a couple of weeks ago
or a few weeks ago.
And he was talking
about, you hear,
it sounds like a scene from
a bad movie going on outside,
with just, it's crazy,
it's really, really crazy.
A police force that
doesn't feel supported,
it's just so many factors.
And I love New York.
So when I say it needs to sink,
I say that from a place of love,
like you need to
sink or you're not,
that's gonna be your only
motivation to wake up.
Maybe it'll wake up voters,
maybe it won't, I don't know.
I think the people who flock
to cities like that now
are perfectly comfortable
folding into a brave new world.
They're comfortable with it.
- Well, I'm so glad
that you said that,
that you want it to come back,
because I spent most of my
adult years in New York City.
My grandparents lived
in New York City,
although I grew
up in Long Island.
So I was always going
to New York city.
I remember as a kid, I hated it
'cause I thought it was
this dirty, weird place.
And then as then I was
an adult and I loved it.
I loved the grittiness and
the reality and the artists
and all of the stuff
that was New York.
And it just doesn't
happen anymore.
Something you said before
that, about the dystopian part,
it wasn't just the
lockdowns and the crime
and all that stuff, but for
me, it was something else in LA
that when I would go to the
supermarket and by the end,
I really stopped going out
because I just hated everybody.
And I was like, I'm just
not gonna go out anymore,
which also isn't healthy.
But I remember that there
was like this blank look
in everybody's face, like
you'd be walking around,
and I'd try to take my mask
off and I'd be yelled at
everywhere I went.
But that there was like, no,
there was no fight
with the people.
And then you could almost
see in a weird way,
how when they talk
about the Holocaust,
how a certain
demonization of people,
a certain you don't look
at other people as human.
And I kind of felt
that weird thing,
like no one was looking
at each other anymore.
We were just these
orbs bouncing around
in the egg section
or the fruit section,
and then go about our lives,
and that is not
healthy for a society.
- Yeah, and people just
bought into this fear
so extensively that they
became afraid of other people.
I mean, I remember watching
a clip on "The View"
that went through my timeline,
that Joy had said
something like,
oh, well, you know, now
that the masks are here,
I mean, why not
always have them on?
Like, (unclear), I mean,
you could get the flu.
First of all, that's idiotic.
From just a scientific
perspective, you know,
that if we're not
exposed to germs,
that's how we build
an immune system,
so it's idiotic on that level.
And it's also like, wow, that
told me something about her.
And it told me something
about a lot of people
that have her ideology,
her worldview,
they're really
comfortable in a world
without that interaction.
Like this whole thing
you're talking about,
like glazed over eyes, follow
authority, do as I'm told,
you're not my friend,
you're my enemy
because you didn't
obey the rules.
There is a segment
of the population
that is very
comfortable with that.
They wanna be told what to do.
They're uncomfortable
making their own decisions.
with other people
This whole idea of
freedom and liberty
is uncomfortable for
them in many ways.
And this was a
manifestation of that.
So it was like, we all need
to sit back and realize
that it's not just people that
are being tugged into this.
There are people that
are willingly walking
into this brave new world,
that they will say, yeah,
sure, oh, take my arm.
I don't need to ask questions
about safety or death,
and no, no, no, I trust you.
And then there's a
segment of the population
that's resistant to that,
that wants to think
for themselves,
that doesn't wanna
be told what to do,
that that wants to be able
to ask tough questions,
and that isn't comfortable
with a government authority
or a bureaucrat or
whoever it may be,
or a corporate bureaucrat
for that matter,
telling them what to do.
The population, the
split in the population
has never been clearer to me.
And a lot of those
zombie types, I'm sorry,
live in these woke cities.
And I don't think they're going,
they wouldn't be
comfortable in a Florida,
because there's too
much risk, Dave.
There's too much risk
in the real world.
- For short though, those
freedom loving people
you're talking about at the end,
those are the racists, right?
I'm just trying to be clear
on what you're saying.
- Racists, homophobe, bigot,
transphobic, you name it,
there's a label for,
choose one for the day.
- All right, Jedediah,
you gave me a great segue here
because you mentioned
Joy Behar and "The View."
And I talk often about
"The View" on this show.
We actually show a warning
before I play clips
from "The View."
And it warns people that
whatever you're gonna see
is either complete
BS or insanity
or something to that effect.
I will say that many years ago,
when I lived on the Upper West,
I lived two blocks
away from Joy Behar.
I would see her on the street,
she was not insane back then.
I know it's hard for
people to believe,
but 10 years ago she was not.
I loved her, admired her, she
was always very sweet to me,
her husband, as well.
In my estimation, she
has lost her mind.
Whoopi has lost her mind.
Sunny, I don't know
what's going on there,
I mean, I don't ever remember
thinking she was sane,
Anna, these are crazy people
that they put at that table.
Jedediah, you sat at that table
for a portion of your life.
And here you are smiling in
the free state of Florida,
explain that to people,
how does this make sense?
- Yeah, I mean, and I
didn't sit there very long,
people may notice, it was
about a year and a half.
I think I tested for the show
for a few months, as I recall,
I was still at Fox,
I actually had one foot
at Fox as a contributor,
and I was testing for that
show at the same time.
Roger Ailes at the
time actually gave me,
signed off on a
like, hey, all right,
she's probably not
gonna get the job,
so let her just, it'll
be good (unclear),
go on over there.
And I was like, I know I
might be, I was like, great,
you don't think I can get
the job, that only helps me.
So I went over
and I have to say,
the show has
changed drastically.
I mean, even in that show, I
mean, that was eight years ago,
it was a very different show.
First of all, it wasn't
as hardwired for politics.
At the time I was hosting
with like Candice Cameron
and Raven Simone, so there
was a lot more pop culture.
But there was also,
it still had that Barbara
Walters feel to it,
where she really valued
different viewpoints.
She defended that.
I don't know if you remember
that show a while ago,
I mean, it was before
I got there for sure,
where Bill O'Reilly was
on and Whoopi walked off.
That was not-
- In many ways, that was
the beginning of the end
in some respects when the
two of them walked off.
- But that wasn't
tolerated by her.
She made it clear that this
would be called "The View"
because there were supposed
to be different views
at the table.
When I got to the show, I have
to say, for the most part,
I had a good dynamic with
the ladies behind the scenes.
There was some concern, I
remember a couple of times,
with a couple of episodes.
For example, the day that
Hillary Clinton was coming on,
which oddly wound up
being a couple of days
before I lost my
job, I don't know.
But regardless who knows?
But the day before,
the day she came on,
I remember there
was a lot of panic
because I was very big
on the email scandal,
and they worried that I was
gonna bring up something
that was uncomfortable.
Like I had asked, hey,
can I show this document
that she signed that said
that she knew exactly
what the C in
confidential meant,
and she lied to
everybody, she lied.
And they were like,
oh, I don't know.
There was a lot of like
walking through the
hallways quickly
and what's Jed gonna do?
I actually didn't get to an
email question, imagine that.
I did ask her a question
about being tone deaf though,
so I felt like that
was gratifying for me.
But there was that, there
was another instance,
I can't recall, I think
maybe it was Maxine Waters,
where I felt like tangible
energy of like, uh-oh, you know.
The thing is though that
after I left the show,
I maintained a good relationship
with the other hosts.
We had emailed here and there.
When I went back,
Dave during Covid.-
- [David] Yeah, it was nuts.
- What the hell happened
to these people?
What happened to them?
What happened to the show?
What's going on here?
I mean, I went through
a full pre-interview,
they knew exactly where
I stood on the mandates.
I was naive, I was naive,
I felt like, well, they
know where I stand,
I'm gonna go on,
they're gonna have a real
conversation with me.
I don't know why I thought that.
But I thought, well,
it would be ridiculous,
I was a former cohost, it
would just be so disrespectful
to do anything but have
a real conversation.
Of course, COVID
became an issue.
I couldn't be on set, even
though I tested COVID negative.
In fact, one time,
I was supposed to
co-host several times,
I was slotted to host, I
think four or five times.
One time they came to my
house, COVID tested me,
I tested negative, I had an
exemption letter from my doctor
that said not only was I not
a risk to people at the time,
they were like,
she's not a risk,
and here's our
negative COVID test,
and this is medically
advised against,
I submit all this stuff.
I test negative and they
say, that's not good enough.
You can't show up tomorrow.
I was like, why'd you test me?
You're testing all
the vaccinated people,
anyway, it made no sense.
But anyway, ultimately they
tell me I can't be in studio.
I do the show remotely, and
everybody saw how that unfolded,
which was a shout fest.
I say two things and I get
shouted down as misinformation.
All I was saying was what
had already been acknowledged
by the CDC, which
is that the vaxxed
can get and spread COVID.
So the mandate didn't
make any sense.
It was very clear like
everyone should make
their own personal decision.
I didn't get an apology.
Sunny went on some tangent
on Instagram of posts
and all this stuff,
responding to me like...
Instead of responding
to me in the show,
because she didn't
have an answer.
She went on Instagram and I
was like, what is going on?
You were at my
wedding, girlfriend,
like what is going on here?
So the commitment
to the ideology
took precedence over
just mutual respect,
over friendships, I'm sorry,
they've lost their
minds over there.
It's it's now a panel
of a bunch of liberals
and one person who wears
the label conservative,
but agrees with them
on all of the things
that they deem must
be agreed with, right?
So it's like, oh, you
can't stray on the vaccine,
so that person has
to sit there now
and basically tow the line of
the fake conservative, right?
They get to say they have
diversity on the panel.
diversity of thought.
But that person, on
these important issues,
like A, B and C, you either
have to tow the line we say,
or you have to make a
really feeble argument
and let us win, is
the bottom line.
So I just don't and you know,
Meghan wasn't like that.
I don't know Meghan
McCain very well,
but I worked with her
a little bit of Fox,
but she she's feisty.
She wasn't taking
any garbage there.
You see how that went.
It's hard.
It's not what they want.
It seems to be that now,
that's just not what
they're looking for.
Diversity of
thought is just not,
it's not what they're
interested in, it's sad.
We could have had
a great discussion
that day about mandates.
I think the audience
would've loved to hear.
But they knew that if
I was allowed to talk,
there would be people
that agreed with me
and they can't have
that, they can't have it.
- For people that have
not seen your appearance
on "The View" that
you're referring to
when they went off
on you on this way,
we did cover it on the show.
So we'll link to that down below
so people can catch
the clips of that,
'cause it's really incredible.
And the dismissive
way they treat you.
And as you said, Sunny
was at your wedding,
like really crazy stuff.
You know, it's funny 'cause
when I play clips of "The View"
and it's usually, obviously,
I'm making fun of them
and in some ways it's
low hanging fruit
in a certain degree,
but that thing for
whatever reason
still is culturally relevant.
And I think it's interesting
that you mentioned
Barbara Walters
because obviously
she was an icon of journalism
and she's not associated with
it anymore as far as I know,
or at least it's very,
very behind the scenes.
And obviously, she's older now,
but when she started that thing,
the very purpose of the
show, it was in the intro,
I remember it 20 years ago,
we're gonna have these women
of different walks of life,
of different beliefs,
of different religions,
of different skin colors,
and we'll talk it all out.
And now it's just bash
the hell out of whoever,
either a fake conservative
or a regular conservative,
who can just take a
beating basically.
And Meghan couldn't
take a beating for that.
Well, she took it
for longer than you.
(unclear)
- It's exhausting.
And also, I mean the whole,
you say that and that is true.
I think for a long time,
that Barbara Walters,
that's all true, but you
always had to wonder like
why is it four against one then?
- Like that doesn't
even make sense.
- Like they should have on there
a Bernie Sanders style Democrat,
they should have a
moderate Democrat,
somebody who's maybe
completely independent,
they have a moderate
Republican and then a harsh,
like a strong, you
wanna really grab,
you're talking about "The View."
It's like I don't need
to see four people
pat each other on the back and
then one person get bullied.
That's not enjoyable to me.
I think that it's
a household name,
it's a show that's been
around for a really long time,
I think people say,
oh my mom watched it,
you know, my aunt watched it,
it was always on in the house
growing up, it's iconic.
But I have to say
like, it turned me off.
I mean, I was really disgusted
with how I was treated
and I'm also disgusted
with the idea that
I see who's going on there now.
And I see what's going
on in the casting,
I could just see it.
Now I know they had a
problem with casting
'cause everybody
had to be vaxxed
and lot of
conservatives were like,
I'm not playing that game.
I wasn't playing it.
Obviously if I couldn't go
guest cohost a bunch of times,
I wasn't gonna be, you know,
a lot of of people
weren't playing that game.
- Maybe that was a great
way for them to weed out
the people they knew
would be a problem
because it gets rid of you,
Lisa Booth, who's phenomenal,
good friend of mine on Fox News.
She refused to do the guest gig
because they wanted her
to get vaxxed to do it.
She said no, and
then it's like, okay,
that takes out half
the competition,
that intellectually
is gonna own you.
- That's exactly right,
because those were people who
this was an issue where
people were saying,
you really had to weed out
people who were saying,
I mean, think about it
though, that's a big show.
You know how many people
would've just got the vaccine
just to do that show.
Because it's an opportunity,
it is an opportunity,
it's an exposure
opportunity, it's all that.
There were people who
were willing to say,
I prioritize my health, I
prioritize my wellbeing,
and I prioritize my integrity
more than doing your show.
And that was just
the bottom line.
I did the same thing as she did.
I said I was lined up to do
I think three guest spots,
plus during my book launch week,
a couple of spots back to back,
we were gonna do a
whole thing for my book.
And I was like, you know what?
I know my book, I know
this is gonna hurt my book.
I know the book has my
son's face on the cover,
but I wanna be able
to tell my kid,
more important than
that I sat on "The View"
to promote the book.
I wanna be able to
tell my kid one day
that I didn't
sacrifice my principles
or what was right for me
or my health or my family
for some show that couldn't
accept a medical exemption
for a vaccine that doesn't
prevent transmission
because they're too doubled
down on their woke ideology
and their dystopian
nightmare to allow
for some diversity of thought,
that's something I'll be
proud to tell my kid one day.
- Can you talk a
little bit about
just the TV production styles.
I don't wanna harp on
"The View" the whole time,
but I think it's important
where now, like, you know,
you in essence do a
version of what I do,
you're talking to the camera,
you obviously have
some preparation when
you do your show,
but it's your thoughts and
they're coming out of you
as you see fit.
And I'm sure you work with
some people behind the scenes.
But it is what it is right
in front of the camera.
Where on television,
whether it's "The View"
or CNN or everything else.
I think a lot of people
don't fully realize
how scripted, how prepared,
how many voices are going into
their heads before the show.
We posted a clip a couple
months ago of Whoopi
talking about the vaccines
and my body, get
your hands off it.
And then the complete reverse
on abortion or no, sorry.
I did it the other way,
where it was vaccines,
it was everybody get injected
or you're gonna be fired
and I'm not gonna sit down
with Jedediah, blah, blah.
And then abortion comes and
it's nobody touch my body,
like how the whole
thing is just nonsense,
it's just nonsense.
- Yeah, that makes no sense too.
And their justification
for that by the way,
was always well the vaccine
affects other people.
No, it doesn't actually, it
doesn't affect other people.
And they say, well,
abortion's only about you,
actually, no, you
have that wrong too,
because abortion
affects a person
living inside the woman's body.
I know I just said woman, and
that's a controversial word.
- You said woman and person,
you're really going for it.
- Red flag's going off
all over the place.
But yeah, the production,
I mean, of these shows what
people don't understand.
And one of the
reasons why I'm doing,
you know, your show was actually
a big inspiration for me,
I don't know if you know that,
we've never had
that conversation.
But I really appreciate
people who are bringing
unfiltered content,
that don't have all of that
going on behind the scenes,
all those people in their ears.
When you do a show like that,
I mean, you go to show meetings,
the topics are
chosen by producers,
based on, you'd sit in a room
and where do you disagree?
Okay, let's go with this
topic, that's how it works.
There's a lot of
producer input on all,
I'm not just talking about
network, on cable news of,
what can be said, of
what shouldn't be said,
of we're not going
in that direction.
You've got a question
you wanna ask,
that's not the way they
want the segment to go,
you don't get to ask it.
So there's a lot of
frustration for people
who just wanna have
a real conversation.
The segments are timed
very short, as you know,
you've done a lot of cable
news segments, I'm sure,
you've done a lot of
segments everywhere.
So you don't really get
to the meat of the matter.
And oftentimes on "The View,"
you'll notice like Whoopi
gets the last word.
So you could be in
the heat of a debate,
and she'll just, you
know, it's wrapped,
but she's gonna get
that last word in.
The audience loves, the
audience is very liberal,
so they'll clap.
It's a very difficult
position to be in.
And truthfully, I
think that over there,
they don't want a
likable conservative,
I think that becomes a problem.
Because if the audience,
when I left that show,
one thing some
people don't know,
is I got a ton of messages
from people that were like,
on the left that were
like, you know what?
I really respected you.
Or that was a problem for them.
Because those people's
eyes and ears were open
and maybe they would be like,
hmm, I was told conservatives
were racist and bigoted,
she doesn't sound that way.
So yeah, there's a lot that
goes into the production,
there's meetings, producers
pick the whole layout
of the topics, there's stuff
you can, and can't say,
there's people looking
over your shoulder.
If you stray, it's like,
oh, she's a problem.
That goes on across the board.
Whereas now I sit at
my, Jedediah Bila LIVE,.
I pick my topics, I
say what I wanna say.
And everyone says
to me now, wow, Jed,
you sound like you're,
it's like Jed on the loose.
And I'm like, well,
it's different.
It's in a sense, you are
not cuffed in any respects,
you're kind of just yourself,
which is something that
really appeals to me
about what you do, what I do,
what a lot of people in the
podcasting space do right now.
- It's a pretty sweet
space to be in, right?
Like this new frontier.
I mean, it's funny 'cause
now I'm like an old veteran
of this because
people always say,
oh Dave, I watch your show,
now I do something like this.
And I'm like, man,
how did I become
the vet in this situation?
But it's great
because it's like,
man, we're still growing as
that thing deserves to fail.
Are you worried that as all
of those institutions fail
and as CNN and the rest of
them fail that people like us
will be the only
people to turn to?
And I think there is some
risk in that, probably,
like we can do the best we can,
but can we solve all of it?
- I listen, I think
it's for the better.
And I absolutely do.
Because I think that people
who are drawn to this space
are free thinkers, I think we're
independent, free thinkers.
And there's a fearlessness to
it that has to accompany this
because listen, you're
out there every day,
you're saying how you feel,
you're gonna be
held accountable.
You're not gonna be
able to fall back on
the cushion of a network
or, oh, you know,
I've got somebody in my ear
telling me to do this or do,
I don't even have an
earpiece on the show,
I don't have anyone talking
to me, so if I go rogue.
- I have one only
so I can hear you.
Nobody else can talk
into this thing.
- If Jed goes rogue,
she goes rogue,
listen, I'm always guys,
if I burn the house down,
I apologize in advance,
to the tech people
that are in the room with me.
But a lot of the individuals
sitting in those network spots
are very uncomfortable with
their own independent thinking.
Like they don't
trust themselves.
They're so programmed.
And a lot of these people
are on the left, in media,
They've been so
programmed again,
like this bow down
to authoritarians,
bow down to authority,
bow down to politicians,
bow down, oh, what
do I need to say?
How do I need to word this?
I mean, I've seen
people on network TV,
sit and figure out
their talking points
of what they're gonna say
in a 20 second sound bite
with a producer and write it
out and read it over and over.
I'm like, can you put that down
and just tell me what you think.
So I would rather have people,
Joe Rogan says all
the time on his show,
he'll be like,
I'm not an expert,
like, I don't know, he's
willing to say, I don't know,
but people respect that
because you're a
free thinking person,
you don't have like
loyalty to this or that,
you're just telling
people what you think.
That's the way to come
to real solutions,
not sitting behind
a cushy network job
where you can say
this and say that,
you're completely
filtered at all times,
because there's always a
worry about this or that.
That's not getting
anybody to any solutions.
So I think it's a good move.
- Were you ever worried on
your little red pill adventure
in terms of like, oh man,
I'm really in this deep?
I think a lot of
people have that.
They start getting red
pilled about stuff.
Maybe during COVID
they were questioning
vaccines or lockdowns.
Then they start
thinking about freedom
a little bit differently.
My God, they maybe read
a Thomas Sowell book
or watched a PragerU video or
saw one of us move to Florida
and they start coming around.
But then they freak out like,
oh my God, everything
I knew was a lie.
Am I really surrounded by
this many crazy people?
Could Andrew Cuomo
and Gavin Newsome
really be devil
worshipers, is it all true?
And it is.
Did you ever have any
moments along the way
where suddenly you were now
more friendly with people
on the right, you were
getting probably tons of hate
from people on left,
where you were like,
wow, this is actually
a little scary?
- No, I'm gonna tell you why.
Because I grew up
as a conservative.
I always fell conservative
and I grew up in New York city
and I went to Columbia
University and I
taught in academia
in a very liberal school.
So I was always
very used to like,
wow, the crazy's going
on around me, I'm not it.
I wasn't drawn to it, and
I was always kind of like,
I always felt kind of like
alone on an island sometimes.
So I don't, I truly,
if I'm being honest,
found it very liberating.
And listen, I've made
the right mad too,
you and I both know that there
are, I am a free thinker.
And I talk about this sometimes,
that sometimes the right,
the fans of President Trump,
the big MAGA fans were always
like, oh, are you anti-Trump,
or you're anti-
And I wasn't at all,
but I was being honest
with the audience.
I was saying like,
hey, I don't know if I'm
seeing a stolen election.
I'm talking to the, help me
help me, what am I missing?
Like, that's who
I am as a person.
I'm someone who's gonna say,
I am seeing a desire to steal
an election as in collusion
from social media, from
big tech, from big pharma,
from the Fauci, I saw
what was going on there,
that they tried to rob
him at that moment.
But I wasn't seeing it when
it came to voting machines,
and tallies, so I was
asking tough questions.
I took heat for that.
And now it's interesting,
a lot of people came back
and said to me, you
know, something,
I gave you a lot
of heat for that.
A lot of the audience
came back and said,
I gave you a lot
of heat for that.
And I regret that because now
I appreciate that about you,
which I love,
and I appreciate that somebody
had that reflective moment.
A lot of people actually
came to me and said that.
But to be honest with
you, when I left Fox,
A lot of people thought I
was gonna leave Fox News,
and I was gonna go work
at CNN, or I was gonna...
You know, they were like,
oh, she's gonna go liberal.
And when they saw
that I actually sound
more conservative.
The message that I really
wanted to get out there
is all I really wanted was
to be completely unleashed.
I felt that need at
this stage of life,
to just kind of let
it all out there.
And I'm on my show,
talking about dating
and relationships a lot.
I'm talking about why
gentlemen have disappeared.
I'm talking about things
that I never had the
opportunity to talk about.
I'm gonna make people mad
on every side of the aisle.
But I'm here to fix stuff
and I'm here to break
stuff down and be real.
And this is the moment for that.
This is the moment in
the podcasting world.
This is kind of our
moment, I feel like.
So I feel liberated
if I'm being honest,
and I never worry if
I'm too conservative.
I mean, now it's kind of fun.
I can, I met Kamala
Harris last week
and I was doing the cackle,
I didn't do a great
cackle, I'm not gonna lie.
I did do, and I said, wow,
it's great to be
able to just do that.
Like, you feel it and you
just let it out, it's great.
- Well, you just realize
it's like, you can say stuff
and if you don't let
them control you,
they can't control you.
So whether I'm trying to
explain Rachel Levine,
he/she, whatever,
guy in a dress, girl,
Leah Thomas has a penis,
he, she, she, whatever,
is the number one
women's swimmer.
And it's like, if you fear
that they're gonna cancel you
over it, they will.
But if you don't fear it,
then it's either funny
to talk about, or at least
you can get it out sensibly.
- 100%, 100%, I think
I feel the same way.
You feel like you're just
able to just, I don't care.
People say to me, are you
afraid to get canceled?
I'm like no, I'm truly,
not even a little bit.
I mean, yeah, would
it be annoying if I
tweet something out
and they suspend you
and then you can't,
you know, it's annoying.
And it is a symptom of a
disease, don't get me wrong.
This desire to
suppress by the mob,
this desire to say, oh,
you think differently,
like, look what was
labeled misinformation.
Most of what was
labeled misinformation
the last two years
wound up being
accurate information.
Let's be honest.
And now you can't
call a man a man,
a woman a woman, biology
ceases to matter,
words ceased to matter.
The word female
has been changed.
Now it's gotta, you know,
everybody's gotta be made to
feel good about themselves.
So we gotta change that
word in the dictionary.
It's all about a,
it's all emotional,
they want a whole, the left
now seems to want a whole world
that's just subjective.
Nothing's grounded in reality,
and nothing's grounded in facts.
And there's a reason for that.
Because in the land of
reality and facts, they lose,
they never come to
the table with facts,
They never come to the
table with policies
that actually work,
they come to the
table with feelings.
They come to the table
with that's not fair,
that's not just, you know,
redistribute the wealth,
and all of this, like,
oh, you know, we need to
create a fair society.
And in the process,
they create a society
where people are outta work,
where people can't afford
to fill their gas tanks,
where people are struggling,
where people view each
other as the enemy,
where community and
family disappear.
I mean, all of these things,
where crime is on the rise,
they break stuff in
the process of trying
to create what's fair,
it's all a language game.
But I'm not interested
in the land of Oz.
I'm not looking to
go over the rainbow
and sit in the little pot
of gold, that doesn't exist.
So I'm comfortable
in the space I'm in.
As you may have noticed, I have-
- Yeah, how do you really feel?
I'm not reading you here,
what's going on here?
- I really should be more
blunt with you, Dave.
I really should.
- So I wanna back
up to something
that you said a
minute or two ago,
about some of the things
that you talk about
besides politics.
You mentioned men and you
mentioned relationships.
I toured with Jordan Peterson
for a year and a half,
and he was always, a large
portion of his audience
was males who were trying
to stand up straight
with their shoulders back,
get their lives in order.
And it does seem like we have
this like dearth in society
of men that have
their shit together,
basically that are kind
of living the right way,
to find a woman or find
a dude or whatever,
but to live like a full
life, it seems worse,
somehow, it seems worse for
men than women right now.
Do you think that's fair to say?
And what do you think
is going on there?
- Well, I think there's
been a demonization of men,
and I think feminism,
and when I say feminism,
I don't mean feminism
as it was intended.
A lot of the founding
feminists were pro-life.
I mean, it was a very
different vision they had.
They were talking about, you
know, equality of opportunity,
they were talking
about a society
where women had the
chance to succeed,
removing those very
legitimate barriers
that existed for
women at the time.
And it was a very pro-life
movement, as I said.
I'm talking about the
feminism of today,
how it's been morphed, how it's
been taken over by the left,
and now it's like,
it's empowering somehow
for women to be slutty.
It's empowering for
women to rag on men.
You saw what happened to
Kavanaugh at that disgraceful...
I mean, they just tore that
man down with no evidence,
they made a decision
about who he was.
This idea that men are bad or,
oh, men should take a
backseat and be quiet
and let the women talk, this
idea of toxic masculinity.
And oftentimes what's referred
to as toxic masculinity
is just men being gentlemen,
men wanting to take
care of themselves,
and take care of their families.
Yes, men being strong.
So I take all of
these things on,
and I think that men in
many ways have it harder.
And this is near
and dear to my heart
because I'm raising
a son, you know,
I'm raising a son at a time
where men are too
easily demonized,
where boys on college campuses
are being told to
sit down and shut up,
it happens all the time
where they're told,
oh, take a back seat,
let the women talk.
Or sexual harassment charges,
just because you're
charged with something,
now means you're
guilty if you're a guy.
So this is all near
and dear to my heart.
I think feminism
has in many ways,
damaged men and damaged women.
I played a clip the
other day on my show
of a woman out
there talking about
how it was empowering
for her to be slutty.
And it was the
patriarchy's fault,
that everything
that happened to her
was the effect of
the patriarchy.
And you know, all this nonsense.
And I'm like they've really
done a disservice to women,
women who now think it's
shameful to be a housewife.
Why?
Or being a mom isn't,
being a mom is the most
important job I have.
It's the most
wonderful, rewarding,
important job that I have.
That was my superpower, right?
Carrying a baby.
That was my superpower,
they've robbed women
of all these...
And now they're robbing
them of more, right.
They're taking their trophies,
they're taking all of their,
oh, woman of the year,
it doesn't go to
biological women anymore,
we've gotta make
everybody feel welcome.
So I think feminism has
done a huge just disservice
in short, to men and to women.
And what should really
exist is mutual respect,
people who respect themselves,
who care about themselves,
who are free
thinking individuals,
and who respect each other,
and that's been lost.
And I think walked
all over by feminism,
of modern day
feminism, I should say.
- There's obviously so
many weird parts of this.
I mean, the idea that the
people who are championing
women are literally
championing a guy with a penis.
I mean, Leah Thomas has a
penis, that's just a fact.
Connor, my director over
here mentioned the other day,
why is he or she
such a good swimmer?
Because maybe it
acts as a propeller.
I thought that that was pretty,
I thought that that was
pretty clever, but...
- Amazing.
- But the people, I mean,
it's good, it's good.
But the people who
were championing women
are now championing
this guy, girl,
whatever you wanna
say, as the winner.
And I think, it
is my belief that,
I think women want
regular dudes.
I think they want those
guys that open the door
and do those gentlemanly things
and actually take
care of themselves.
The other meme on this one is
that every other week,
Daily Beast or Salon,
or one of these
idiotic websites, write
how working out is now
part of the alt right.
The far right is using
fitness as a tool to recruit..
- It's like all of these things
that would make you feel
empowered as a person, right?
All of these things,
health and wellness,
being fit, feeling strong,
wanting a strong man beside you,
wanting a gentleman, being
comfortable in your own skin,
these are all
things, you know why?
Because they want a society
of dependence, right?
They want you weak, they
want you subservient,
they want you feeling
unhappy with yourself.
So now you have to what?
Maybe go live in the metaverse
and maybe a big tech guy
can go make a bunch of money
off of it because you're too
afraid to enter the real world.
- Don't forget the
prescription pills.
Don't forget the
- Exactly right. I was
just gonna get to that.
They want you chronically ill
because then you're a repeat
customer for big pharma.
And this idea of being
healthy and fortified,
and that's very threatening
to a lot of the ideologies
espoused by the left, and
a lot of people they love,
and they change dollars
with oftentimes, whatever,
in terms of big pharma, I mean.
So yeah, this sense of
personal responsibility,
this is their enemy, this
is their number one enemy
I do think that women
one gentlemen, I do.
I think that those women
that buy into this nonsense
all the time and hear all
this nonsense about how,
oh, when a guy opens
a door for you,
they're just trying to
make you feel small.
No, honey, they're
trying to be a gentleman.
He knows, he knows that when
he opened the door for you,
that you could if you
wanted to, you got arms,
you can open it yourself,
he's trying to be respectful.
Most women absolutely
do want that.
And most women want a man
who can defend himself.
Most women want a man who cares
about taking care of himself
and his family.
They want a man, they
don't want a boy.
They don't want a boy
who needs a safe space,
they want a man.
And they've been trained that
that's a bad thing somehow.
And some of them take the bait
and you know what winds
up to those people?
Those women wind
up very unhappy.
They wind up very unhappy,
very, very unhappy in life,
because they're listening
to this nonsense
and wind up alone, oftentimes,
because they've bought the
story, they've bought the story.
So I think a lot of it is about,
rejecting modern day feminism
is about embracing
female empowerment.
It's not about tearing it down.
It's about saying you,
it's, you, you dress slutty,
you attract the wrong kind
of guy, that's on you.
That's on you.
Own your own decisions,
your own choices,
and what is the result of
those choices, own it all.
And you'll feel some
control over your own life
for a change.
- Jedediah, as you know, I am
off the grid at the moment,
this is a delayed taping,
so I am somewhere right now,
possibly a father,
unknown at the moment,
but I'm off the grid.
Do you ever do any kind of
off the grid, disconnect,
any version of any of that?
I think I've seen you maybe
tweet about some weekends off
or that kind of thing.
- Yeah.
- Because you know, when
you're in this machine,
it just kind of never stops
and you've been able to
stay sane throughout this.
- Yeah, I mean, I don't
know if I'd say sane,
but I'm trying my
best, but yeah...
- Well, I always
say roughly sane,
if you're roughly sane these
days, you're good in my book
and I have a pretty
wide lane on that.
- Yeah, exactly.
The news cycle can
be very challenging.
It's a crazy world.
I don't know if you know
anything about the books
that I wrote before,
"Dear Hartley,"
but I wrote a book
called "#DoNotDisturb."
And it was about that.
It was about the need to
kind of remove yourself
from technology,
take those breaks.
It was a lot about,
actually it predated a
lot of what we know about
social media now, and a
lot of the conversation,
and talked about like how
we're being programmed
to be a bunch of
addicted robots,
and how much joy and peace
and sanity we get back when
we just take that time away.
So I will take, I don't know,
in the past couple of years,
I don't know if I've
taken a block of time,
but I'll even take
a couple of days
where I'll just
shut the phone off.
I'll let everybody
know, like, hey,
I'm spending time with my
family, I'm recharging,
I'm gonna watch a good movie,
I'm gonna walk on the beach,
I'm gonna absorb a sunset,
I don't wanna know
what's going on.
Like, believe me, it's not
gonna break that badly,
you can wait another day.
And it's very, very
important, I find,
and I find people that
even aren't in media,
life is hard right now
for a lot of people,
people are struggling,
they've lost their jobs,
in many cases, they're
going to the grocery store
and inflation has prices
sky high of common goods
and services, you
know, gas prices,
it's scary for a lot of people.
And I've been in that position.
You know, Dave, I don't know
how much you know about me,
but I was a waitress,
I grew up in a very
middle class family
that struggled financially.
I didn't have money.
So I understand what
financial struggle means.
I was a teacher, like
kind of like struggling
to pay bills for a long time.
So I know that feeling and
I think it's so important
to kind of in those moments,
I think get away
from your phone,
step away, recharge
with your family,
remember what's good
about your life,
remember what feels good.
Nature is always
very restorative.
It's essential or you'll
really lose your mind.
You'll wind up then stressed,
the next thing you know,
you've got anxiety.
Then you got big pharma rolling
in with their medication.
- Thank you, my friend,
I look forward to seeing
you in Florida in the fall.
- Thanks so much, Dave.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about the media,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our media playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out the full episode playlist,
they're both right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.